my boyfriend or whatever they use like a
mean old biker dude you know and he's
like he says make make us like when we
[ __ ] up you know you make you come in
the room with a loaded 12-gauge Mossberg
and you rack all the shelves out of it
and they make us hold the [ __ ]
shotgun like this and stand on our tippy
toes and like when we started buckling
you whip us and [ __ ] you know you put
guns to our head and all kinds of [ __ ]
you know there's one of your dad's
friends
yeah actually was but my mom ended up
like being with them you know oh well
yeah so David you grew up where and
we're Whittier I was born in with your
Hospital suburb Oh I decided our life
for south east south you see until I
bought your family you you grew up with
two parents yeah my mom my dad but I
mean I was about four years old my my
dad you know catching the death penalty
for the murder my my next-door neighbors
was crazier than my sound but he was a
usual like strung out on dope you know
mostly they speed heroin cocaine you
know speedballing and stuff and I guess
one night he spoke into my neighbor's
house and two elderly people who need
butchered him you know stabbed them each
like 40 sometimes and bashed her heads
in with like blunt force injuries or
whatever it was you know you know but uh
yeah you went to prison so you did
murdered the next-door neighbor yeah
to to a to elderly people to elderly
people yeah and uh yeah that was a
sleeping next door you know you were
home for you're four years old you
remember this yeah I remember coming
home and about a week later they found
the bodies you know I remember coming
home and it was all taped off and
there's all kinds of police cars and
your we are a little McDonald's Happy
Meals and you know never you know they
kind of like rushed us you know rush my
mom like a where's Larry where's Larry
you know we're looking for Gary we
needed to see there that's my dad
there's your dad yeah that's pretty much
all I remember of that you know some day
he was convicted
oh yeah he was convicted he was actually
given a judgment of death on November
4th 1987 which happened to be my
birthday yeah so you did get the death
penalty on your birthday on my birthday
yes yes no I never went to go see him or
nothing but I used to ride him what's
the while you know what's it like
growing up with a dad who's on death row
it's uh it's life-changing I think you
know I think it's a milestone you know I
lived in and I lived in a house up to
like off and on it's a couple years ago
so you guys lived in the same house oh
yeah after that oh yeah we stayed there
yeah and there's actually my grandma's
house but me and my mom mother my sister
we all stayed there you know yeah
like sometimes I mean my brother would
be walking down the street and people be
yelling out door ain't gonna be just
like your dad you know or like hey [ __ ]
you yeah are you talking about yeah yeah
you know actually I mean so you you so
did your dad got the death penalty and
yeah he's gone now he actually died uh
they over actually overturned his death
sentence in like 2005 I believe but
that's because he's they failed to like
bring up the fact that he was abused as
a child you know you know they
overturned they gave him life without
you know oh is that right yeah he got
off he got off of death row but they
just put him in a regular prison yeah
so to him it was like being Frieden you
know and then he passed away area I
passed away about two years ago yeah
yeah so he his abuse is this child this
childhood was oh yeah tell me about that
Sally no of it from reading reading uh
you know Google whatever you know his
whole transcripts or whatever it is yeah
I guess he was he was born out of
wedlock so they singled him out you know
and it burns burn him with cigarettes
and feed him scraps and sit him to
school and like tattered clothes and
make him sleep outside on like a box
spring and and lock him to closets all
that crazy stuff you know and then they
would like give him up to the system
you were sent to like these he's uh I
was like orphanages or whatever it is
you know or they sexually abused them
and physically abused them and
everything else you know yeah it's his
childhood it sounds horrible
yeah and then how was your childhood my
childhood was it was uh it was different
yeah cuz my mom end up like me with
somebody else it was like a crazy biker
dude you know you know let's go back a
bit to your dad so your dad murdered the
next-door neighbor the circumstances
around that circumstances were just the
fact I believe he's just out of his mind
from doing drugs which drugs heroin and
cocaine and speed and he would do like
speed balls and stuff you know you know
I don't know but possessed him to break
into my neighbor's house and you know
steal some stuff from some old people
you know you know elderly couple but he
ends up stabbing them both you know to
death before he's just a drunk drug
binge yeah thing or I don't know I
believe he described it as uh he didn't
know what he was doing it was like like
these like little figures coming at home
or something like that you know but I
mean I'm sure he was conscious of what
he was doing you know did you did have
that personality of somebody who was I
had violent or I didn't I only have good
memories of my dad you know I don't have
no bad memories of my daddy at all
you know okay so to know your childhood
my childhood was I was a little rough
off and on you know I would I was always
in trouble you know at school you know
like she had from Kenya for preschool up
I would always get kicked out of school
you know started started doing dope
around
13 years old and seeing I was sent to
like programs you know or we call that
like residential programs or whatever
you know for kids that are [ __ ] up you
know bad you know till I was about 17
you know and they let me out and that's
when I started doing more dope you know
speed mostly you know you know like my
family got kind of tired of that and
kicked me out you know so I was homeless
when I was only 17 years old
running around the streets you know just
getting high stealing [ __ ] you know no
gang banging you know fewer games yeah
yeah which game for you and you're
Caucasian yeah I was out from Hispanic
game videos mostly Hispanic yeah where
your game yeah okay yeah she won in like
my homeboys are from my neighborhood
actually jumped me in to my neighborhood
was actually stat ended up stabbing me
18 times hitting me a head with the
hammer and you know the scar on your
forehead is yeah yeah hit me came over
and he just asked me for a shot of dope
you know and I was like alright yeah
sure come in you know I see nothing
coming and all of a sudden he just I was
making out his dope and he he asked me
for it already yeah he picked up a
hammer he said this is a nice hammer you
just cracked me up the hammer I flew
over the bed I was had a little baby
you're like right next to me you know my
girlfriend's baby was only eight months
old you know it was right next to me yes
meters hammer and a fire were too bad
and he just starts stabbing me you know
for no reason whatsoever
yeah you know one way or another I made
it out and made to my neighbor's house
and actually the same I collapsed on the
same the same house that my dad murdered
my neighbors you know so I thought I was
gonna die right there on their steps but
I know living it lifted me the us use
USC or one of those places
UC Irvine it earlier UC Irvine
saved my life
and pretty much after that
hmm I have I know like no direction you
know I wanted to do something like I
want to be like that no more you know so
my sister brought me down here to LA
mission and I saw I got down here you
know I saw end up down here at downtown
LA you know I always thought down having
a leg [ __ ] that you know I going to
downtown oh hey you know it's crazy down
there yeah but yeah you know graduating
one of these programs and but I was
strung out all the time you know so what
it was you're drunk today
faint no no no did you go from here with
the family
yeah yeah yeah I think it probably I
kind of you know graduated yeah cuz I
heroin does it won't do nothing
everywhere yeah phantos is just like
this new new thing that just came in you
know like crack like hit the eighties
you know that's what fentanyl is doing
you know to this area yeah oh yeah a lot
of people like heroin only and a lot of
people like defending alone yeah it's
just I guess there's just certain
preference you know a lot of people are
afraid of fentanyl I've seen a lot of
people OD on fentanyl
thank you Andy i I have not no leads on
thing you know or anything but I brought
people back thank you
about at least five people back promote
game you know next girlfriend she od'd
on me
in my house my friend other day just OD
Tommy in my house a couple other people
I always had like narcan memory you know
yes when you say your house I live in my
sorrow know who you are yeah
all right here on at the rosin yeah yeah
I finally got housing and stuff you know
housing yeah it's usually the attics
yeah yeah well because I graduated the
program here you know and uh and I told
my need housing you know I graduated
program you guys got a gave me housing
yeah and you don't give me housing but I
mean all those people in the SRO they're
just they're all getting high and [ __ ]
you know I just I believe the people I
hurt like they're living the chance and
stuff it's just like that they choose to
like like living these kids you know and
cuz they they like you know the
lifestyle you know selling dope getting
high not having to pay rent you know I
mean what yeah so do you uh what you do
for money I'm on SSI I got that's aside
from for when I got stabbed PTSD and uh
sorry I'm unnecessary I catch X right
about 9:45 a month they'll offer that do
you feel like somehow you're following
your dad's footsteps not not that you're
murdering anybody that just drug use oh
yeah definitely definitely definitely
was like a milestone in my life you know
is that when it happened I believe I
would you know get any ordinary you know
suburb kid you know I don't think I'd be
downtown now today right now you know
but yeah
going up like that was uh it was
definitely a life changer yeah did you
have kids if you're up I do I have a
little girl where she she's uh Mike my
sister doctor she's uh she's ten now she
just turned came out a day well I don't
want custody ever nothing but yeah so
where do you think your life goes from
here from here you can find a lot of
editors tough to touch to snap out of it
yeah
you know it but it's all about choices
you know I believe that either I'll snap
out of it or I don't know I really
couldn't tell you know this is my life
he just it takes all kinds of weird turn
you know sure he does
you have it I mean I'm just trying to
keep my head above water right now you
know basically oh the dad have murders
the next door neighbor's at four years
old you're destined to have some unique
struggles yeah definitely even my
brother and you know you like he's a
little different too you know but he's
not gonna tell me about your suppose my
brother well my sister actually came out
she's like the most normal one you know
if you don't do drugs and she went to
school she has a good job in staffing up
but my brother just like me he runs the
streets sells dope does dope you know
steal [ __ ] and you know hustles and you
know pretty much sing [ __ ] it's me
you just doesn't do it down here he does
it in Long Beach yeah so you have some
other interesting scars on your body
oh yeah it's from getting stabbed right
here
this one good staff I got hit my lung my
colon this is uh he's on the chest and
there's because he'd try to carve out my
heart this is from when I got stabbed
no no this one I got stabbed from dude
oh yeah this is wrong because I got
hitting my colon when he stabbed me they
had to open me up yeah this one is from
a from heart surgery because I got into
a car sir endocarditis from a slamming
bad dope down here
you know you're lucky to be alive
oh yeah okay I've got it yeah yeah
definitely I definitely got a couple
chances you know I hope I'm not blowing
it you know all right David thank you
for sharing your unique story thank you
Dudek
you